little women atlanta star miss juicy
baby is on the road to recovery after
suffering a stroke last month in a
statement posted to her instagram page
monday reps for ms juicy real name
charlene king pearson confirmed that she
had a stroke but add that she's no
longer in the icu for now she's in a
different part of the hospital and up
next they write there is a new journey
ahead of her for healing miss juicy is a
very private person and wants everyone
to know she is fighting and ready to go
home she wants to thank her fans for
showing so much love and keeping her in
their prayers and if fans feel inclined
to donate ms juicy's sister started a
gofundme page to help cover hospital and
household bills their goal 25 thousand
dollars
ms juicy baby first fell ill when she
suffered a stroke on april 28th the next
day a post on her instagram account
revealed that she had been stabilized in
the icu and in ms juicy fashion she
updated her fans by using her signature
catchphrase i'm still the queen of
atlanta boo i'm the queen of atlanta of
course miss juicy rose to fame on the
hit lifetime reality series she was a
guest on the show's first season in 2016
and got promoted to a full-time cast
member in season two
listen to that crowd they love me
and her following you could say it's
pretty loyal with over half a million
followers on instagram miss juicy also
has her own youtube page featuring
collab videos with stars like david
dobrik i want you guys to meet my friend
it's miss juicy
oh my god oh my god oh my god you're
quiet
[Music]
and once she recovers there's no doubt
miss juicy will continue bringing the
laughs everybody that know me no not in
my taglines miss juicy baby
[Music]
you